and that's what you gotta let I mean we
gotta let go as actors we can't it's
none of our business what other people
think about it okay but on the same note
I have a question for you I listened to
one of your episodes lately with the guy
from The Flash no this is good okay you
guys are talking about how you can never
you can never allow yourself to really
enjoy your experience and and part of my
heart broke because it's like a lot of
actors go their whole career is never
able to enjoy anything they've ever done
I was so disappointed and freaked out
that wasn't what I intended and I still
do that like I'll watch whether it's
recently a Hallmark movie or an episode
of The Flash I'll watch it
and I'll hate the way I look I I didn't
accomplish if I wait I forget what I
intended
right and I can appreciate what I did
and I don't think anyone's ever been
able to say why you can like it's it's
you know I mean like a lot of people go
through their lives just you know like
I'm so miserable and misery is such a
motivation because I'm not a cocky like
overconfident person by any means I
actually am like very insecure a lot of
the time and beat myself very
self-loathing but like you said like I
mean I was like why would I be doing
this if I didn't think like oh yeah I'm
gonna be on Broadway oh yeah I'm gonna
right be able to do this like why would
I be
why would I be doing this I'm I'm really
hard on myself too I'm like oh my gosh
look at me
and I started to I mean look you don't
ever let that go I don't care who you
are people say oh come on just you gotta
let it go you gotta you know it's it's
my friends would give me [ __ ] about that
but I I try not to watch things right
away like you said give it some time and
then I actually can go back now I hadn't
seen an episode of Smallville in years
and I saw an old episode that was like
on it was a hula oh I'm like you know
why the hell I'm not and I go
I used to think he looked so terrible
bald and you looked like [ __ ] and hit it
and now I'm like dude you actually look
at her to be 10 years younger and I
don't know how to get through that but I
guess my point I did that going through
Smallville and now the time has passed I
actually am not able to appreciate it
somehow right and I don't know you just
spoke specifically about how like you
never happy no I'm sorry not been here
I'm happy but like when you perform
you're like uh it stresses me out I try
I just want to enjoy myself I I don't
think I've ever really there are moments
when I'm really comfortable and set and
I enjoy things but overall I put so much
pressure on myself to be great that it's
hard to enjoy what you're doing when you
just are always striving to be great and
not just enjoying the moment I think
that goes with life it's like if you're
not in the moment how are you going to
enjoy it you're always ahead of yourself
you're stressing out about things I
think just an aside as I'm getting older
I'm like sitting into things more and
I'm finding it much quicker you know
back on Smallville I'd be like give me
the tear stick I need like an hour I
need to look at videos of dogs being put
down like I I need to do that and now
it's like okay just let me know when
we're rolling give me a minute
and then like I know where it is now
right I feel comfortable in it like I
I've experienced life for 36 years
and I want to share this I'm always on
edge I feel like I'm always I have like
my whole life's been I have to be great
I have to be great at this I have to
come through I have to show them that
I'm great I can't I have to know my
lines and said I have of course you know
and that drives me up a wall where I
wish I could sit there and say
have settled into myself I'm fine I'm
fine I can just do this I know what I'm
doing it's not that I don't know what
I'm doing but I I second guess myself a
lot I think that's normal like I still
do that how is Grant Gustin as a human
being it's one of the most rewarding
experiences because
people always ask me what
what Grant is like but Grant works from
his truth so
what you see
uh there's a there's a fund there's a
spark and there's an Exquisite
vulnerability since probably four or
five I've dealt with like anxiety
depression like I've had real I had
really weird anxious type dreams as like
a really young kid and
um I mean it's I don't want to get too
into it but like we we before we got
married we started doing couples therapy
just to like
you know be ready for marriage before
there was really nothing going on in the
marriage and then all kinds of things
for both of us start to like come to the
surface and as good presence and couple
and like as individuals and all kinds of
I mean I I was I knew I had always dealt
with anxiety but putting like you know
getting pinpointed ideas about where
things started and why you were feeling
that way anxiety is ever present in my
life for sure so what it's so depression
though this is something I dealt with
for the first time and and you know I
have an understanding of what I think I
personally this is not like I'm not a
scientist here you know I think I
understand where depression comes from
talk about it but what is it for you I
just curious where where you think um I
think it's these these uh I think you
know they always say the past is
depression and the future is anxiety
when you're thinking into the future
you're thinking anxiety anything in the
past is through the depression
um I think with me is uh when I get
anxious or when I I'm in pain I I almost
feel feel a sense of I'm not whole I'm
not complete I'm not perfect I'm not all
these things and it gives me anxiety
thinking how do I get back to normalcy
and what is normalcy and oh you just
yeah I mean there's there's only been a
couple times that I've that I feel like
it's really on me but it's like
it's just like you're outside of your
own head back here
um and you just
you're just out of it like you're just
you're not where you want to be and then
that creates more anxiety and then it
just like it compounds yeah you're hyper
aware of of all these these these
negative things you're ruminating and
all these negative things which now
appear to be real but they're really not
but you're making them feel real right
yeah but the circumstances I'm talking
about were what I was not in control of
the environment
um
whereas like what you're talking about
is interesting to me because you know in
that convention space you're complete
control yeah the anxiety is still crept
in
um is this making you anxious you know
it's weird and this is uh
it's it's been a little rough for me to
talk about because I you know I don't
want people to have the
reception that's uh like a fake anxiety
it's a fake concern because I'm really
like fortunate right now
um but I am still suffering from like
horrible anxiety and it's just you know
some days I just wake up and I just I
don't want to get out of bed I don't
even want to wake up you know because
once I once I got settled down back in
La after all of it after all the dust
settled I was like
I could I couldn't get up in the morning
like you know the things that you talk
about depression like you know only
wanted to sleep all the time it felt so
foreign to me somebody with like this
zest for life and this energy that's you
know I mean this drive this work ethic
like it's it's insatiable and to feel
like I don't I can't get out of bed
I didn't understand why I would want to
anyway and then feeling like now I'm
just a burden to my family that my kids
are seeing me like this I can't let them
see me like this this is I'm like this
shell of myself and they see me in bed
all day it's just depressing as hell and
I think like to myself like I'm feeling
like this and I'm fortunate like how are
people who are like suffering who are
losing everything they have in their you
know families are going hungry and they
don't even have you know they can't put
food on the table they don't have access
to food or they just don't have they've
run out of money yeah how are they doing
with this so it's like it's it's a tough
thing for me to talk about openly
because I don't feel like I have the
right to to you know to complain or me
but I am uh yeah it's killing me I
couldn't believe how open and honest uh
Alan was it's great coming coming out of
that season of busyness and and all that
thematic energy for far longer than we
should ever have to sustain that kind of
energy this
I you know this this crisis of like
faith in humanity you know
um a little bit of uncertainty of like
where I should be right now and identity
crisis
you came to your wife and you told her
honestly this is what I'm feeling and
this is what I'm thinking and I don't
want to ruin this marriage but these are
kind of what I came to her and I said I
think it's better if I'm not here
really yeah and what'd she say please
don't do anything crazy
you know it was a very real company like
here meaning like if you weren't alive
yeah you were that bad you were dark it
was very I could not pull myself out of
it well you it sounds like when after
the whole Superman thing you know you
think thank God in a way because let's
say the sequels happened you would have
been you wouldn't have changed you would
that would have lingered on like a
freaking cranberry song who knows you
know who knows but the fact that it is
really broken down in a bad way or
lashed out or done some other thing
because I wouldn't have had you know I
wouldn't have had the experiences that I
did have the loss yeah that I did have
to help how much of a better person you
think you are from that experience and
growing and figuring all that out in
those [ __ ] moments where you're just
sobbing and growing as by the way you
weren't that old when that's when this
happened 25 25 yeah I thought I knew
everything of course we always do it's
crazy but it's been all flash for six
years which I know you know all too well
yeah but I I think that you know if you
look back right now I definitely don't
have I mean I'm sure people say I don't
have regrets in fact my uncle got
tattooed no regrets I'm like [ __ ] that's
a lot I don't think you know I think I
don't think you know what I under that
you should put like a caption like uh
not entirely true yeah yeah because we
all have regrets I have regrets though I
mean that's the thing you always you
have to prove yourself and I'm like
listening to you and it's funny
because sometimes I think I'm gonna have
nothing in common with people and then
you start talking I think we all have
things that are in common like
there is an ego ego is such a big part
of everyone's life that they probably
ruin a lot of opportunities and I
remember I had opportunities but it was
ego it was lack of discipline uh I don't
want to go learn this I I just I I was
sort of embarrassing if I look back I'm
like you [ __ ] pompous little [ __ ] for
you to go you know you have an audition
with uh you know Tom Hanks or something
I mean I've worked on that one but uh
you know Goodwill Hunting and Saving
Private Ryan and I remember those like
the night before partying I was a kid I
was like 26. and I was like I'm gonna go
I didn't give a [ __ ] like I I wasn't
maturing by the way maturity isn't
something that is in my vocabulary but
I'm very responsible and you know it
takes time you say it takes time to sort
of like look back and go hey this is
this is where I was [ __ ] up this is
this is why and you said you learn you
relearn things I've talked about this
before but I I wasn't relearning I had I
had to learn all these things I had to
learn all the things that I didn't learn
as a child and so
there's a lot of growing up that I've
done probably in the last the most grown
up I've done in the last year and a half
of just between doing this podcast and
like talking to folks like you and and
so just sort of digging deep and like
it's funny because I'm watching you like
there's still things that you're
figuring out we're all figuring out I
know I would never trade off where I'm
at right now to be somewhere else in my
life or in my career I mean I have like
I think one thing I really struggle with
we were me and my wife were talking
about it recently and me and my mom had
the conversation all the time she's the
one that really pointed out
I have
imposter syndrome for sure like I don't
think I ever deserve anything that I get
or that like I not you know worthy or I
didn't work hard enough for it or
someone else worked harder or was more
talented so like that's something I
struggle with all the time you know
um just being like okay with where I'm
at and feeling like I worked I deserve
it and
or earned it um
I think that goes with life it's like if
you're not in the moment how are you
going to enjoy it you're always ahead of
yourself you're stressing out about
things and how do you how do you deal
with that well I you know you brought up
having kids my kids have taught me how
to be in the moment because
I mean when you're on set you're in the
moment because somebody says action or
go and you're you know you're there
right and if you're not there you you
probably don't stand a chance at least
for that scene or whatnot but with your
kids and maybe your frustrations
building or this and that but you're
like but even my wife has told me it's
like it's all temporary so it's going to
change in probably 15 minutes anyway
whatever's going on the happiness or the
or the frustration so just just enjoy it
because your kids are going to grow and
they're going to be gone before you know
it but when you look back and you think
uh you know I deflected I started
playing Warcraft my wife's doing this
did you do you remember even like having
any breakdowns any emotional moments any
like crying spout you know bouts of like
uh just like God what's the matter with
me I'm emasculating myself you know did
you ever feel like that yeah I mean I'm
not gonna go into detail because that's
uh you know but but there was a moment
and that was the moment when I when I
when things started to change
um
crying sobbing on the floor
um because I was I was shown I was I
finally
I I find it allowed myself to come I was
in a vulnerable enough place I guess to
come face to face with
with
how people saw me so I had that you have
this vision of who you are right and
then there's how people see you and when
those two things are incongruent when
they don't come together they don't
match up you look in the mirror and
what's looking back at you is other
person's reflection of who you are it's
like what wait a second no no they're
for a long time you go they're wrong
right they're wrong they're they're
wrong it's not me right I know who I am
but if you really allow that to
see that it's like it can be devastating
every day it was like why I mean like
how why am I so lucky and I've kind of
every step of the way it's not like that
I can tell you why because that's the
thing that's hard because when people's
perception of you is obviously different
from the perception you have of yourself
obviously you know I'm talented this and
that but like I look at you and I'm like
it's a good looking guy he's really
talented but all that aside the best
trait about you from just knowing you
and I think which is the most important
with anybody is who they are as a person
people see that and if it translates
they want to be around you they they
like you know you're very likable that's
I mean that's that's a huge thing so
going through that whole trauma of
Superman Returns the end of Superman
Returns was a long drawn out process of
me in denial for much of it and
thankfully I guess I didn't I didn't
lean on drugs or alcohol yeah parting I
played World of Warcraft endlessly yeah
and that was my addiction
um and then you know a few other games
along the way but but that was where I
lost myself and spent way too much much
time it took me a long time to come to
terms with that that was an addiction to
beat the game
I'd be a worker wait it's still going
wait they keep wait a minute well you
saw what happened with with Stephen you
know obviously we've talked about it
nine times and I thought that was so
brave and like I think nowadays you
could sort of talk about that thing
especially in this show it it just
without a doubt I didn't know this was
gonna happen but it helps it just helps
people they're like oh my God this guy's
so successful he's so and he deals with
anxiety how does he deal with it and
it's just like you know you're not
saying this is the answer to fix your
anxiety this is like this is what I do
to help me do you think that you're
you're uh you have yet to mourn this
show like being done with it do you
think that's going to hit you when you
least expect it or do you think you're
like you're just it's been so that
you're pretty much done this is you're
good you've been wanting this to end
even though you love it you love the
fans
I I do love I do love the fans
um I just don't want any responsibility
right now other than
a husband and father
I really don't are you gonna go see
someone or you're not gonna do that I
might
I think I might we live in a culture
right now that not right now we have the
Western culture you know as long as
capitalism has been around
that feeds this idea into our minds from
the a very young age that says if you
aren't grinding yourself down you're not
you're not working hard enough and if
you don't work hard enough you won't be
successful you know this correlation
between hard work and fatigue and
success
Elon Musk you know I think tweeted
recently something that was just sort of
you know if you're not working 80 90
hours a week you're not you know you
don't deserve it whatever it is you're
after I don't know you know that's a lot
not not quoting him but but you know and
it's um you know the fact that we
should feel like you know we deserve
poverty or somebody deserves poverty
because they decide to rest their body a
little bit is a ridiculous idea you know
I mean is it hot in here or am I just
sweating hang on a second
you are slow I am I don't know why
lights
hey look if you're cool with me sweating
I'll just sit here and sweat no
don't worry about it man
yeah okay I noticed it but I'm not
sweating
honestly man
I think I might be sick you want to
throw up
yeah well come on use my bathroom
I uh I might have to cut this short man
I'm not feeling well at all really yeah
well why don't you I you leave if you
want but why don't first you drink some
water I'm gonna get you some Tylenol no
I I think I just gotta go do you want me
to bring it home let me drive you home I
actually just kind of want to walk
do you mind yeah I I just need I just
need fresh air
come on thanks buddy uh what you just
heard was a guy who was exhausted and um
you know they're as much as he plays a
superhero on TV uh you know we're human
beings and I commend him for coming back
and talking to me but he had to go he
had to cut this interview short as you
hear and it was it was a little bit uh
it was a little crazy as you're gonna
hear yeah that idea that like you know
we should be we should be going all the
time is crazy crazy it's good that's
really I think that's what kills us Ryan
was a little freaked out right Ryan yeah
it was yeah oh really well he says you
were white you know he's just like I
just hope he's okay I don't know and but
I know panic attacks I know
overwhelmingness and I could tell you
were sweating I tell you and that really
I don't know you just weren't well for
starters I shouldn't have I knew it I
should have canceled yeah for sure yeah
you're yeah I don't know why in fact I
said that that why would you like your
yeah so
um you just love the [ __ ] pocket yeah
I do well I mean I left here I tried to
drive I tried no I I walked home tried
to you pulled up beside me and tried to
drive me I drove down the street I was
freezing on the walk but not because I
was I was just freezing because
um I was just spot in the cold sweating
in the cold and
I got uh I got home I got onto the couch
put a blanket over me and again was
freezing but just sweating
uh bullets and um
you know just told my wife I just said
I'm having a I had a really bad panic
attack and uh I text her after I said I
just got to check up on him oh really I
did she didn't you know don't please
don't say anything and that's but I was
worried about you and that's why I was
like [ __ ] you know Jess was like well
or who said it maybe it was just like
well it's rush hour all these cars and
he's having panic attack and that I was
racing down like dude get my truck
you're like I'm fine yeah I just wanted
to listen to a I wanted to listen to a
podcast and walk by myself actually not
yours right that's all right it's okay
it's okay you left mine to listen to
another it's totally it totally makes
sense dude do you ever feel like
I'm still alone in a way sometimes I
think there's been times I think like
when we were doing Smallville there was
a lot of loneliness because I didn't
know how to navigate that and maybe I
kind of kept everybody away because I
just I wanted to be alone because one I
didn't have any time alone but I listen
I'm I mean
I don't mind being by myself I I mean
everybody needs time to themselves
um as you know I just moved and got some
more space up in Northern California
and at least for an hour a day I go
outside and I'm up in the hills in the
mountains and by myself and that's
it's like a I don't see it as an act of
meditation but it probably is it just
gets me out yeah same thing the reality
of it all how you do get down you do get
depressed you do get anxious you do
you're not happy with the way things are
going sometimes and um that's life man
that's freaking life